so today i'll be talking a little bit
about some of ncbi's resources for stars
chronovirus to
assemble data and how to access it
my name is anita hatcher i will be
talking about ncbi virus and
in a few minutes we'll switch over to
newla or leery to hear about the
datasets project
then cbi hires a long history of
providing access to many different kinds
of genetic
and health-related data that data is
stored in different ways to accommodate
all of our customers
so i thought it might be useful to give
an overview of where data is stored and
how it can be accessed in ways that
hopefully suit your workflow
so genbank up here in this top circle
probably the one that most people here
are more familiar with
holds assembled sequence data including
complete genomes
and several types of metadata describing
the samples where the
sequences came from genbank is part of
an insdc collaboration
and data is synchronized with ena in
europe and ddbj
in japan and down here in this circle is
bioproject and biosample
those records also hold metadata
describing the sample or the way that a
sequence was produced
biosample can have fields that are more
precise than genbank but also more
flexible
which can be good or not so good excuse
me
but there's a gray bar a vertical gray
block box okay perfect
thanks so let me see
so biosample it has
more fields and you can add fields to
the biosample record so it can be a
little bit more precise than what you
can put into
for example in genbank but because it's
more flexible that can be
good or bad depending on how people are
entering the information
the bio project and biosample are
usually associated with
sra records although they can be
associated with genbank records too
sra is the sequence read archive it
holds
high throughput sequencing data
sometimes that's called short reads
or raw reads if you're interested in
learning more about sra
i think we're scheduled for a talk about
june 30th
in the june 30th spheres meeting
so each one of of these data sets
are directly accessible but we've been
working to make the data easier to reach
so ncbi virus here in the center
it includes all of the viral records
from genbank
as well as viral reference sequences and
taxonomy structure
the best way to access it is a web page
but if you're more interested
in programmatic ways of accessing the
same data at least for stars coronavirus
then you would probably prefer the tools
from the datasets team and these are the
two that we'll be discussing today is
virus and datasets
so our goal for ncbi virus is to
facilitate access to viral data from
genbank and refseq
whether you're interested in nucleotide
or protein sequences
we normalize much of the metadata and we
have
interactive visualizations that help
summarize and help you select the data
that you're interested in
once you've selected sequences you can
do a quick alignment or a phylogenetic
tree
and you can download the data in several
formats so you have to do less massaging
before you can use it in another
analysis
so after records are pulled from genbank
we have a curation process to normalize
the metadata so for example
the isolation source for the sample
could say something like serum
pbmcs plasma so on but those terms would
all be synonymized to blood
so now you only have to filter by one
term to retrieve all of those records
and several other fields are also
normalized like host
geographic locations terms associated
with
lab vaccine or environmental samples and
our team is working on
pulling some fields from biosample when
they're not included in the genbank
record
especially like the collection location
and the date that are missing for a lot
of the sars cove records
and then on the last side over here we
also generate refseqs
these are representatives of a species
and we try to update the gene and
protein annotation especially for the
more well studied viruses
the normalized data for ncbi virus is
provided through a few different
interfaces including our stars
coronavirus 2 dashboard that you see
here
this lets you use interactive widgets to
select records by
like the world or u.s location uh when
they were collected or when they were
released in genbank
but i think a lot of us have been moving
to graphics because it can tell a story
about the data
right so i'll pick on my home state of
georgia so you can see it highlighted
here with a yellow dot that means it's
selected
and you can see on the top time slider
that most of the sequences from georgia
were collected
starting around december and then they
started being submitted and released to
the public
pretty quickly after that which is
that's nice
we have plans to add another section to
this dashboard so you can see mutations
that are associated with selected
sequences
or you can do the reverse and search by
mutations to see how the records are
distributed over
time and space so if you think that's
interesting we are really happy to hear
what you would find more more useful or
most useful how you would be using that
data
after making selections in the dashboard
you can come to our main page or you can
also start searches from here
we have a variety of filters here on the
left
including a new filter to search by
pangolin lineages
as ryan mentioned these are recalculated
daily and we're working on a log of
changes
to record how pangolin reassignment may
may change over time
i'll be highlighting just a couple of
other of these lineages
so there's an accession filter where you
can of course search for genbank
accessions but you can also search for
records
that are associated with bio project
biosample or sra records
you can limit your search to records
that code for a certain protein or
search by a submitter's name we're also
working on a filter that would limit
your records returned by the number of
ends in the sequences because we know
that those ends can mess up analyses
sometimes
most of these columns in the table are
sortable
and you can also change the columns that
are shown using the select columns menu
here
these tabs that are highlighted in red
above the table
they let you switch between nucleotide
records protein records or refseq
genomes
in this case though the refseq genomes
are really more useful
like for segmented viruses and not so
much for stars coronavirus ii
so once you've gone through the
filtering process or you've used one of
the dashboards
you can go to the download menu
so you would start here on the download
results
and we've been improving these options
so please let us know if there's
anything
there that you that you don't see that
you would like to do so in the first
step of the menu you would choose
whether you want to download sequence
data in a fasta format
a list of accessions or a table of the
metadata
if you select sequence data you can
build custom def
lines that's shown up here
and you can add any of the fields that
we have available in the table to the
custom def line
if you choose the metadata table then
you can also choose which fields you
would like to include
in that table
also for each of these you can choose to
get the accessions with
or without the version numbers there's
examples down here
with the version is more precise but i
understand that sometimes it doesn't
play nicely with other tools
another option is to see your selected
sequences in multiple sequence alignment
and this tool has some nice upgrades
recently so you can choose the color
scheme for the bases or like show
metadata columns you can also build a
phylogenetic tree to see an overview of
relationships in the data and both of
these processes happen pretty quickly
if you get stuck anywhere and we hope
that you don't because we understand
that everybody is pretty busy right now
we have a help page with documentation
there's also a contact us link on at
this location on almost all of our pages
you can write questions or comments and
you can include images that can help
like clarify the question that you're
asking
and down at the bottom down here we also
have a green feedback
button it has a very short poll but that
helps us to understand areas where we
should be prioritizing for
improvement and with that i want to say
thank you to
the team everybody's been working really
hard to support your work and i hope you
feel free to contact me directly either
through email or through slack and maybe
give us a visit if you haven't before
and with that i am going to switch so
that newla can present her portion
i'm going to stop sharing for just a
moment
okay thank you hey can i take control
okay
okay um thank you thank you everyone for
being here um so just as a way of
introduction um
i just want to go back around on what um
datasets it's a new resource
at ncbi um that's tasked with
creating new uh user-friendly web
interfaces and programmatic interfaces
for retrieving sequence of metadata from
across ncbi
so our model is that we deliver data as
a coherent
data package that contains both metadata
and the sequence data in a single
zip file and the goals of our project
really are to make it easier for people
to find this data but also to make it
easier for them to incorporate this data
into their bioinformatic workflows
and i said this was a new project um and
at the beginning of 2020 we were working
on delivering data for the reference
genomes and gene collections
endemic started we turned our attention
to the sars2 genbank genomes and we
created
data packages to deliver these genomes
as they were coming in
so to go over what exactly i mean by
these data packages i hope you can see
um so we take all of our data from
ncbi virus the data we deliver comes
from ncbi virus
as i mentioned we deliver it as a
package zip file
and we have two main packages one is
called our then the other is our protein
package
the genome package contains sequence and
metadata
for all the sars2 gem banks that
includes the genomic sequence the
protein sequence
and the underlying nucleotide sequence
for the proteins the protein package
lets you get uh data sequence metadata
for
specific proteins different requests
just like protein or a collection of
several proteins
and so this practice doesn't include the
genomic sequence it just has a sequence
for the proteins and the underlying
nucleotide sequence both packages have
a data report that has the extensive
metadata
that we take from ncbi virus and that
data report is in
adjacent lines format so
um this is important part of the package
we want to have the state report in a
way that can be used
programmatically and we document all
of the data that's in our data report so
you can go to our documentation i've
referenced it down here
and you can find the schemas for our
from everything that's in the metadata
report and a description and some
examples
so how exactly do you access this data
through data sets um
we know we have diverse users so we
created web interfaces we also created a
command line tool
and we also have an open api
so just to present to start with the web
interfaces um this
is our uh web interface for our genomes
so this web interface only has
complete genomes it has a few filters so
um it has filters for refseq or genbank
and for host
and for release date and then it has two
download options so you can download the
table and that comes in different
formats like json lines or tsc
so you can download just the metadata
directly or you can download the data
set which is that package of data that
has both the sequence and the metadata
we also have the protein page so this
page lets you select the proteins that
you're interested in
there's also a cartoon of the genome and
again you have these few filters here
and i want to point out these numbers
are different than what you see on the
coronavirus genomes page and that's
because
there are some genomes that are not
annotated so this includes
a package of data for only those
proteins that are annotated on
zenbank genomes
you're looking for specific variants you
can just query that directly through
ncbi
so if you're looking for specific
lineages excuse me
then you can just put go to ncbi
homepage enter the lineage that you're
interested in
this box will come up and it has a
download
option here so if you select the
download you'll get only those genomes
that
are that assigned angle lineage
we also have a command line tool we
actually have two command line tools
the first is called data sets and it's
for downloading
sequence and metadata the second command
line tool we have is called data format
and that tool is for converting that
json lines
data report into a tabular format
and our tool is available on for linux
or mac
or windows and i include a link down
here
that it's documentation to show you how
to
access those tools you can find out more
information about the command line
structures
and all the flags that we have again in
our documentation and our reference
section it'll give you all the
information on all the commands and all
the flags that are available we also
have these how-to guides so they will
help you
they're short you know workflows that
can help you get started with the tool
so the command line does allow you to
customize your data set you can
customize it
by by choosing file types and also by
filtering the data set so there's a few
more filters that are available
through the command line so um here's
just showing you
the command for the default package and
that's what i showed you
but you can also set these flags and i
just want to point out a few of them
one is annotated so again this is if you
if you have this flat if you use a flag
it's going to exclude those genomes that
don't have any annotation on them
the complete only flag is also um for
filtering those genomes that are labeled
as in genbank and the complete
completeness is defined by the submitter
primarily
so i just want to make a point that
there are several there are 100
maybe hundreds of thousands of genomes
that are labeled as partial but i think
some of our users may consider those to
be complete so if you want the full data
set um
don't use the complete flag these slides
also allow you to exclude certain files
if you don't want the protein files or
cds files
you can exclude those and we also have a
lineage string
flag here so you can download a specific
lineage
so our data fool again allows you to
convert that json lines report into tsv
or excel
and all the fields that you can choose
from the data report
are in our documentation so you can
those that have this demonic here
you can use those with the data format
tool to just pull out those fields
and we also in our um how-to about
working with
json lines data reports so we offer you
different suggestions about how to
how to use that data report
lastly we also have an open documented
api
and you know the api that we have serves
as our
single mechanism for delivering data to
all of our applications
and we have python in our libraries
that'll help you
use api and just want to point out that
we have jupyter notebooks that we've
created and you can find them through
our github site and they're referenced
in our documentation and they'll help
you get started using
these languages with our api so
lastly i just want to make the point
that this project is in
active development we are making
production releases every
week or so and we really want your
feedback so
um we are very user driven and we do
read our feedback button every day i
if you have any questions please email
me or send to info at ncbi
um for those that get in their opinions
early um
we can you know deliver what you need so
thank you very much and i'll take any
questions
i get i have a quick question the uh so
for the
downloading uh stars covey data from the
apis and the various
uh available data sets are there uh
filters that this group should be aware
of that are sort of by default applied
or like if if the goal is to collect
genomic surveillance um is there are
there any caveats that we should
associate with
um or that or the analysis that has been
done to sort of characterize cavs that
should be associated with
um the data that's being provided
um no the default package should give
you everything
um it's uh so yeah if you don't set
those
annotated or complete flags you should
get everything
and um and the data should be identical
to what's in um antibiotic virus
god thank you this actually might be a
good uh
good segue on segway but we can take a
quick
tangent um 20
do you want to talk a little bit about
uh purpose of sequencing
i mean it's been discussed in the
context of the phage metadata
specification but
um some of the ddc thoughts around them
could i ask one more question
on the last presentation before we move
on
or maybe that wasn't really moving on um
no no it wasn't moving on at all it was
just taking a side trip
into purpose of sequencing and ensuring
that uh
you know because i think andrew's
question was around um
around how you actually know what the
purpose
the context in which the data set was uh
was pulled
i'll i'll hold my question until after
no uh usb like baseline surveillance
yeah i um so uh one of the flags that we
had requested through both kiss aiden
and zbi
and walby sending those guidance out
part of the reason we hadn't
actually talked about it is because we
are looking through clearance for some
of our guidance
um so the main purpose behind this was
we wanted to be able to
use sequences that are generated outside
of cdc so most of our variant calling
proportions
all the data that we know was randomly
collected is the only thing that's
included in any of the proportion
tracking any
any data that cdc has been putting out
um
and and we've received requests from
various partners saying they have been
sequencing how could they get their data
included
we have run this analysis uh different
ways uh through using a giselle or a
portion of it and we always end up with
certain biases because oftentimes
there's outbreak investigation there's
close contact investigation of eocs and
so on and so forth so
that seems to bias our cause of
saying what the baseline is um so this
guidance will
is an attempt to define rather define
what does not constitute baseline
surveillance so if there was a targeted
reason
uh like uh sg drop off for b117s and
lately for one other way to forget the
name of that people have been using
uh so-and-so trying to say what if you
are targeting uh
for a particular reason other than
surveillance any set of sequences they
should not be tagged with baseline
but everything else that's just part of
your routine surveillance that was
collected
randomly sampled would be so that we can
start including them
in the various analysis that that is
done by cdc
but um as usual it is stuck in
bureaucratic uh clearance uh process and
once that's ready it will be sent out
published so and uh we have worked with
both kisset and ncbi they've been kind
enough to have this thing in place
i know noodles team worked hard at it
and that particular tag is also
available
through data set downloads now um all of
our sequences ever since we put this
into place
have been tagged with this particular
tag
um so you should be able to expand it
further but this will give you some
baseline data so you can
uh track hopefully true proportions of
various variants without
the bias introduced by sampling this is
ryan i just want to before we run out of
time
uh robert asked a question
um in the chat about if we are
assembling
the uh sample submitted starts to sample
submitted to sra this is robert
petit i think's um question um and so
the short answer is yes we are currently
we're
assembling contigs um doing reference
guided assembly
um and the contacts are available
in aws odp so it's free of egress
we can share more details on slack or
reach out feel free to reach out to me
ryan connor
on the slack but i also wanted to note
that
um partly via ongoing discussions with
dewani and cdc
we're at the early stages of uh sort of
trying to set up a pipeline that would
automatically generate
a genbank submission on behalf of the
submitter that submits to sra
for sars2 um submissions so
we're doing it and we're hoping to make
it um more readily
sort of available to um sra submitters
and particularly um in a way that would
limit the amount of submission work they
have to do to get their data in this
place and then of course it'd be a
standard
assembly pipeline applied to all of this
uh dr wyman you had a question oh just a
quick question
so um for the command line
interface for data does it give you
access to all of the metadata and the
biosample
records and do you have any access to
sra as well through that
that's a great question um we're in the
process of adding the sra accessions to
their data reports but we don't have
access to the data itself um for
biosample a
similar situation we are now in the
process of adding
what we will probably be a separate data
report in the in the package for
biosample when those biosamples are
associated with gemini genomes
we'll include all of them but you can't
query
specific biosample metadata
fields through it no not right now
we have the biosampling session there
right excellent any other
questions or feedback i'm just going to
pitch uh this is ryan again sorry um
i i'm gonna speak for all the ncbiers
that presented we love feedback
and lydia commented in the chat lydia
fleischmann
for the sra the genbank pipeline i just
mentioned
that sounds interesting to you or you or
it makes you
think of some strong opinions we
definitely want to hear them so feel
free to reach out
to us and i just i'll make one last
point someone mentioned about um
the reliability of the data sets tool um
we are working on caching some of the
most popular
data sets that are accessed um and that
seems to
significant speed up in download time
and reliability and hopefully that's
in it's actually but it's a little bit
so hopefully we'll have it
stopping the channel sounds good and
i don't know that we could have planned
this any better we are exactly at the
top of the hour
really excited about these updates from
uh from ncbi and some of the new
features
and uh look forward to continued
development thanks
you